Zakala Khar Dr. Zakir Nayak for this
enlightening talk on the subject similarities
between Hinduism and
Islam we will now throw the floor open for an open
question and answer
session but before that let
me make the
rules clear so that we can conduct the session in
proper and fit
manner please make your queue at the four mikes
provided to you there is a mike
provided for the ladies at the back a mike
for the gents at the back and a mike each at
my right and my left in the
front please understand that this is a
question time and not a lecture time so
please pose your question properly and
to the
point volunteers at the mike are
requested to see to it that the non
Muslims in the queue are given first
preference to pose the question we now begin the
question answer session
and can we have the first question from the
brother on my
left  This so name is
Yogananda this opportunity this is to pay
the thanks to almighty Allah for today
peace to us has been sown through Dr.
Zakir
Nayak peace to us for the Hindu Muslim
unity so thanks very much for very great
effort taken by going through the way this is a
big task done but
another part of him is he will touch the matter of
Vedanta and Siddhanta in another one it is there also if there is still more he can give very
good
evidences and it will be very good for the peace
to us for the future ok thank you very much
a thank you full to the brothers come and
accept and I am aware there are many things more we
can talk normally my
talk is for no hour to 15 minutes today I
request him to go and speak for one and a half
and I spoke for 40
minutes and I am aware that what ever we do what ever
We do research it just drop in the
own and for more information you can refer to
my cassette the concept of God in major
scriptures and my books are written on
topics
in his isla I can get more knowledge by naam it see i am
a non muslim badar n
mic yes badar can we have your name and
profession
so well i am shashank shekhar from ranchi jharkhand i am
doing ma engineering from satya
engineering college here sir my lecture after
reading lecture was about misbelief about islam
and muslims one
sir i have been to jammu and kashmir and
seen the trauma and pain the people are suffering there because
of the so called jihad of some
muslims sir my question is does islam
support such activities if no then what actually
the word jihad mean is it in
accord with the 56 verses of the 1st chapter
of quran wa saaye do not mischief and  The 4th
verse of the 4th chapter says forgiven is
better than written and the 3rd verse of the fifth
chapter states if any one killed a
person he kills the mankind sir i have one more question
in the same context and it is that does
islam teach to give priority to
the religion that is dharma and mazhab before the
country and motherland that is matribhoomi and
thanks a lot first of all
regarding the
concept of jihad he is from wa people fighting
for kashmir now jihad d islam enrage this
fighting what the meaning of jihad does it not
degree
w brother s f jihad is concern there is a
misconception not only among non muslims
but also among the muslims so
most of the people think that anyone is killed
by any muslim for any region whether it be for
personal gain whether it be for  Politics
Weather for Language Weather for Color It is
called a Jihad Jihad does not mean any word fat by
any Muslim Jihad comes from the Arabic
word Jada means to struggle Jada means to
struggle so Jihad basically means to strive to
struggle and in the Islamic
context it means to struggle against one's own evil
inclination it also means to strive
to make the society better it even includes
to strive in the battle field to fight in
self-defense Jihad also means to fight
against operations and tiye Jihad basically means to
struggle many people
Misconception that Jihad means Holy and many
people Translate Jihad is Holy the
Arabic word for Holy is Harb Muksa If you
read the Quran you know in the Quran not a single
verse now the authentic Hadith is the word
Har Muksa  No
other term Jihad is holy at all This was
holy and was first used by historians to
describe the Crusades of the Crusades which
spread criticism and among many people including some
Muslim slid
karmas The translation is holy
translation Jihad means one of the
striving can include fighting Fighting also should be in the
way of Allah Subhan
Ta'ala That is Kita Sablah
Regarding a question the way Islam encourages fighting and
killing and there are many critics of
Islam normally Islam is the reason it loves says that you should kill
the non-Muslims or find them Many
critics including the critic
of India Arun Suri and he writes in his
book The World of Fatwa He is quoted in Sura Taba
Chapter number No. Verse number F and says the
Quran says we are Kafir  into bracket
Hindu that you kill them and if you open the
Quran Sra Taba Chapter 9 verse number fi and
if you read it does say that you find a Kafir you
kill but this is a quotation out of
context for the quotation if you read the
first few verses it speaks about a
peace treaty between the Mushrik of Mecca and
the Muslims if you read Sra Tauba Chapter 9
first few verses it speaks about a
peace treaty between the Muslim and Mush of
Mecca now this peace treaty was unilaterally
broken by the Mushrik of Mecca by the time
Allah subhana ta'ala reche verse number fi he gave them
ultimatum to the Mushrik and he told them put thing straight
in four months time otherwise
a declaration of war and in the
battlefield Allah says that when the Jews come to
attack you you kill the Jews so this verse is
revealed  In the battlefield that when the enemies come to kill
you don't get scared fight them but
naturally any army general today to boost up the
morale of his soldiers he will say that when
the enemies come to kill them he says just be
quiet and ask them to be quiet after coding verse
number five he jumps to verse number
six because verse number six has the reply sara
taba chapter 9 verse number six says that if the
infidel if the enemy seeks asam if they want peace don't just give it to them
escort them to a
place of
security if the enemy wants peace and
quiet escort them to a place of security today
the most murderous army general maximum kills
soldiers then let the enemy go yah says don't just let them go and
ask them to a place
of security so when ever the enemies are giving up
killing including the verses of  Sur
Affal Chapter 8 Verse No. 60 One they say that
prepare your steed and be prepared attack the
enemy the next verse says but if the enemy is
inclined towards peace you give it to them
so almost all the verses we talk about
fighting after that it says that if they want peace peace
is better no regarding a
question what about the verses of Sur
Mada Chapter 5 Verse No. 32 Sur Nisa Chapter 4
Verse No. 40 That if anyone that is a hun being whole this
is the basic rule of Ilam that if anyone kills a hun being whether a
Muslim or a
Muslim unless it is for murder and for
creating mischief in the land spreading
corruption in the land it is a lot of trouble and if
anyone says a human being it is a lot of trouble if you read
Bhagavad Gita Bhagavad Gita
Chapter Number Verse Number 50 It says Krishna
Shri Krishna tells Arjun to do Jihad
Strive If you read Mahabharata Mahabharata talks about
thousands of verses of fighting thousands of
verses many number of times more than what the
Quran speaks Mahabharata is a scripture so you should be aware it talks about a feud a fight
between the Pandavas and the five brothers
Pandavas and 100 brothers fight and Bhagavad Gita
is a part of Mahabharata 18 Chapter in which
Shri Krishna Lord he gives advice to Arjun
Arjun says
Arjun says in Bhagavad Gita Chapter Number Verse 4 46 I would prefer getting killed
anonymously than fighting
my cousin how can I fight my cousin I prefer getting killed anonymously fight it is fought caution you say
in chapter number Verse Number at how could such come in my mind it is successful how could you become
so  It is so important how could your
heart become so weak so Lord Krishna says true
thoughts are important they are important they are sinful it will prevent you from
going to
the heavenly planet going to janna after that
Bhagavad Gita chapter number two verse number
31 33 says he says Lord Krishna says to
Arjuna that it is the duty of a kshatriya
to fight if he does not fight he shall not go
to heaven and if you do not fight you are doing
a sin
so if you are in Bhagavad Gita you have to
fight against if I take the advice of Bhagavad Gita and say to Arjuna you have to be lenient if I am of the worst in
class it is like if you have to
fight against falsehood for the truth you can fight against anyone in
fight for justice in this I am a relative
no problem so  The message of Bhagavad Gita
and Mahabharata is fighting with each other and false is the moment
Hindus know that Mahabharata and Bhagavad Gita have the
knowledge that they know but Mahabharata and Bhagavad Gita
fight between them and false is the same as the one
Quran so moment Bhagavad Gita Mahabharata
understand Quran better and further than this
Quran talking about Jihad if you do Jihad if you go
to Jannah many critics
including a Shari quote and given in Hadith
Bukhari number four in the book of Jihad
chapter number eight Hadith 46 it says that Mujahid
is a person who fights in the way of Allah
Subhan Taala and Allah alone knows who fights
and further prophet said that if Mujahid fights in the
battlefield he goes to Jannah he will get
Paradise but if he returns back he does not do he return back
with the booty of war this
Hadith and from Quran  Quoted by the
critics of Islam I wonder how could the
Hindu critics quote things from the Bhagavad
Gita is the Mahabharata even Shri Krishna himself
mentions Bhagavad Gita chapter number 1 verse number
37 O Arjun O son of Kunti rise up and
fight in if you are killed no problem you will go
to heaven and if you return back
successfully you will get the good riches of this
earthly world same thing is said in the Hadith son of Krishna
to Arjun that fight if you are killed no
problem you will go to heaven if you return back
successfully you will get the word that is the same thing as
Bukhari says what the Quran says
so later you should understand it better by
reading the scripture so Islam is fighting
as the last resort in self defense and to
fight as an operation otherwise no and jihad means
to strife to slaughter no coming to second
question is  It is more important to
follow the
rules of the country or following the religion than it is asking me who I belong
to first,
my father and my mother,
first
brother as for following the country and my mighty God as for our
creator he is most superior to us. Following
the rules of the country is more important than any other rule
laid down by father, mother and country but I am
Indian I know there is not a
single law in the Indian constitution which
prevents any Muslim in India to follow
Islam in fact India is one of the few
countries which mention in the constitution that it is the right it is the
birth right of every
citizen of India to preach and practice his religion what I am doing there is
not a single law in India which
prevents me from doing something it is compulsory or
compulsive for doing something it is haram there is
no law I can offer for all time  what if i did what can't offer there is
not a single law
in the Indian constitution which
prevents me from becoming a good
muslim there for s f i am concern i am a
very practicing muslim
alhamdulillah and also practicing
indian and i am by definition
by geographical definition an
indian geographically i am called hindu so if
hindu means a geographical definition i am
a hindu living in india and i am
practicing muslim
brother can i have your name and your
profession first please my name is shravana
kumar i am working in
bank i understood many people not only become hindu
most of them did not know what
veda but do you agree veda scripture and
veda chapters everything it correct then some
section of the people are hindu only learning that
vedas not many hindu are learning they are not
allowed to rn but two religion leaders
also not practicing the same what veda  Says it is
correct then why they are doing light
please answer me thank you so much first
question do i believe in everything of the
vedas from point no to the vedas only
selected few hindu ld people they read
others are prevent from reading why point no do i
believe in anything of the vedas if you say
allah from the quran it is chapter no
13 number 38 from allah that we have sent
revelation in every age lesson
by name li for
aaran ra zabur iz al aaran
the quran is the last and final lesson
of allah sula wa ril to the last and
final messenger pray salam now the pen on
bamba not can i consider vedas to be the word
of god do i consider vedas totally to be
correct see by name only for i mention torah zabur
iz and quran but there are many books
Revealed by Allah Subhan Ta'ala now
regarding Veda can I consider the word of
God since Veda is not mentioned by name in the
Quran nor any that had I cannot say for sure that it is
the word of God I can say it may be it may be it may be it may be not but even if Veda was the word
of God it is the
last and final law
and then say this from Allah to traffic
with it for miraculous praise they have earned they have been given
for what they deserve now we
believe that all the previous
scriptures of the mighty God by the passage of
time they have got corrupted they have been changed
today we do not have the Injil in the pure form
the Bible that we have it is not the Injil with
wa rit salaam they have changed in the passage of
time so even if Veda was the word of God
today it has not  maintain it in pure form and
all the Hindu scholars
agree so Allah says in Sara Hijr chapter
15 verse no. 1 that we have revealed the
Quran and we shall guide from corruption Quran
is also called as the Furqan the criteria
to judge right from color so what I say that what ever
is matching with the Quran in the
Vedas I accept it to be true what does not
match I leave it aside
because Vedas have maintained it in pure form and all the Hindu
scholars agree so what I say what ever match
with Quran I say have no objection this
part may be the word of God but I don't agree anything
in Vedas is unscientific but in Vedas I have nothing to do with giving I can give any
objection so what I say this is Furqan
katea check if it may be with this we agree it to be the
part which is to be
true
Question from the sister's side I have a
non Muslim sister who is queen
Good evening everybody I am Aarti I am an
engineering
student I believe most religions are just
set of
beliefs Hinduism is a belief Islam is a belief
Christianity is a
belief and most major religions like
Islam and Hinduism Hinduism and Christianity have been
formed through ages they have come past through lots of
ages so there can be
a lot of additions and subtractions which can
add value to the religion and which can also cause some kind of
demolition to the name of the religion
itself so my question is why do we have to stick on to two few
religious books
like the Quran and the Vedas to follow a life
of our own why can't we just take the
rights the positives and the negatives and
leave the negatives alone and take the positives
of the Quran and take the  The post of the Vedas
alone and lead a life of good and no matter what
for example no matter what
the Vedas say and no matter what the Quran says I
believe that a man should have a single wife
and I would definitely I would definitely not agree upon
the fact that the Vedas contain something like that
and the Quran contains something like that it
is up to my count to leave aside the
negatives of how ever great a religious book
might be and take the pot of the book alone and
why are we here to even discuss about the I mean why are we here to even
discuss about the differences and
similarities between the two great religions
why can't we just take the pot of both ridges
and just lead a life of our own sister a very
good
[praise] question very
good question a very relevant
question  We should follow religion like
Hinduism or Islam or Christianity or not follow the
good things of India and what it ends up in, who will decide what is
good or what is
bad for example in America wearing
skirts and shirts is common in western
country
so for that wearing skirts and shirts is common if you were in
China if a girl was on the street wearing shirts
and skirts you will see a woman
including your sister in your street so what is a woman
in America if you don't
come to America then meet an
Indian woman, if she is a woman then she looks
very Indian then she looks very
belly so for that the American one looks very American
so who will decide if you go to
Muslim countries or Arab countries looking at a woman looking at a
woman is very simple as
you don't touch a woman you can talk to her or you can look at it more modest then
you don't greet
the Indian there  Namaste without touching in the
western countries it is common that you shake
hands so shaking hands between a lady and
a man is modesty as you shake hands and
do not touch any other part of the body in some
western countries is modesty in other western
countries kissing a woman on the lips and the
cheek is modesty in some western countries you can do what you want
the male and the female can do it vulgarly it is modesty who will decide who will decide who will
decide if you go to America there are nude
beaches there ship is in the times of India
two months back a new cruise a nude cruise nude
everyone in the ship will be nude for them it is modesty who will
decide the best
person to decide the creator sister i am
asking you who will decide what is right what is right
side and if you say that select the
best i am with you i agree with you
sister select the best of all the  Religious so that's what I've done I've
selected the best
from the
Vedas but what is best is not best
for you is the problem I will discuss that also I challenge I challenge any
human
being to point out the single principle of
Islam which is against us as a whole
[praise]
I challenge I say I am not speaking on
behalf of the other Muslims I am putting my
head on the gin I challenge any one any one yes they may be
non muslims think certain thing is right
for example the sister degrees with
the man having more than one wife I will discuss that
inshallah after I give ya the answer ya
inshallah good will ya will be a poet apple if you ask
problem ups to me how much ya don't know
the answer ya give ya the answer if you know the answer
you get convinced so what you have to
discuss  The thing is you don't agree you can come to
the microphone and tell me I am just a
student I will try best with
Allah help you and reply now do the
Vedas say you canary [ __ ] one wife the Quran Bible says
the Quran say now you don't believe in all
of them no problem let's talk about
logic let's talk about logic sister do you know
by nature male and female are
born in equal proportion but if you ask
any paediatrician a doctor of
children he will tell you that the female
child can fight the germs and diseases better than
the male child so in the paediatric age it self there are more male children
dying as
compared to female children so in
paediatric age it self there are more
females than the males as life goes on they died due to
cigarette smoking death due to
alcoholism death due to  Accident that due to
war more males are dying as compared
to females so today in the world there are
millions of women more in the world are compared
to males only in some country third world
country like India the female population is
less than the male population you know why because of
female if side according to BBC
report BBC report according to
Emily Bacon on the program later die the
topic was assignment every day more than 3000 females are being
attended in India after IIFA the
females that means more than 1 million females are being
attended in India every year after they
identified the females if you stop this
evil practice and according to Tamil Nadu
government hospital report this is the state of
yours that report says out of 10 females born alive
four are put to death do you say it is right it is wrong if you
stop this
evil practice even in India the female
population will become more  Then the male population
in America alone there are 7.8 million females more than males
in UK alone there are 4 million
females more than males in Germany alone there are
5 million females more than males in Russia alone there are
9 million females more than males God alone knows how many
millions of females there are in
the world suppose sister
hypothetical when suppose
my sister has to live in
America and suppose your sister has to live in
America USA and the market is saturated
every man has to find women for himself yet they will be
7.8 million females will not find life
partners no only option remaining for them these
females have got no life partner is that either
marry a man who already has a wife
and become public
property you may say public property
brother Zakir really a hash word sister it is the
most sophisticated word I can use I
cannot use  A better word in America on
average the style is tell us a person has eight
different sexual partners before you settle down
with one mistress is common you can have
10 20 30 no problem 100 also the law will not say anything if you marry more than one
wife
that thing dozen go down their throat why in
mistresses the woman does not get a right she
is degraded she is dishonored in Islam when you have
a second wife you have to give
equal rights she has respect she has respect
but I do agree with
you sister I agree with you that no woman no
woman under normal sir  I would like to
share a husband with any other woman I agree
with you I agree with your sister but the
basic law of the Islamic Sharia is let a
small loss take place to prevent a big loss
let a small loss take place to prevent a
big loss so all the Muslims all the Muslims one know that there are
millions of one if they would not let the husband to have more than one
wife they are
public property they say we would not mind
sharing a husband to prevent our other sisters to
become public property hope to answer the
question
[praise]
next queen
badar bangalore inier but publishing man k
shudra shakti I do agree with Dr Zakir Nayak that is one good concern
but Mr Nayak said the reform of him
not believing Vedas not
Puranas it so can I agree with Kalki avatar
and second queen come kum wanaart if
Kalki Purana and the verse of Kalki could bring peace
With the two religions in India they got
publicity to it and to other people
second thing is
you said the Hindu you quoted Vedas and a
friend of mine also posed question that these
Vedas are not allowed to be read by all it's the
fact among Hindus they are four varnas
except Brahman the other three varnas are not allowed to
read only the Kshatriyas and Vaishyas
can read but Shudras are never allowed to read
Vedas they had no access to Vedas so what
is Hinduism come later can you can you call
the Shudras are also Hindu badar very good
why you said you said Hindu is
excuse me brother people belonging to certain
area do agree please ask one question
at a time brother ask two questions I do agree
with the second question I did not answer because I did not know
the answer I  I gave the
first answer ask one question at a time you can ask
the second question no problem im here
my flight is 4:30 in the
morning one question at a time and I am glad if I don't know I will tell you I don't know
brother I ask two questions and I give the
first answer when I sat down I realised I
forgot I am a human being I am not
a
computer so the second question after I sat
on I realised I gave the answer thank you for
reminding your main question first question
you said that the Hindu reformer said don't
follow old only follow Vedas so why have
I quoted the Quran if I leave it out
what will happen brother towards the end of
my talk I told you very clearly that I have
quoted Vedas as well as the other Hindu
scriptures even if you remove it from my  Talk
all the quotations of all the other scriptures
beside the Vedas my talk would be the same I am talking about
the last and final
messenger not only from the Purana not only
from Kalga Purana I gave so many
references from Vedas I think if you want I can
repeat it do you want to repeat
Rigveda Book Number One Hymn Number 13 Verse Number Three
Rigveda Book Number One Hymn Number 18 Verse
Number Three Rigveda Book Number One Hymn Number 142
Verse Number Three 10 and hundreds of
quotations only from Vedas Talking about
Prophet Muhammad Salla Sallam I told you
in my talk that even if you remove Kalki
Purana remove Kalki avatar there is Nara
Shansa there is Qauma there is Andhu in Atharva
Veda in Samaveda in Rigveda all the four Vedas all four
100% all
four  Prophecy mention my talk only for few limited
time yak
purana k pasli phalo bhan
to kamy i
no hindu respect bhagavad gita
respect purana derar aa bhagavad gita ir
pura aa bhagavad gita derha rigveda
erni that
my take b majority would be same answer the question now coming
to your question with the
other brother post that why in hindism
only certain people allowed to read the
scripture others are not and you are right that
brahmins are allowed to read and shastras are not allowed
to listen and shudras are not a shudra
hindu according to vedas almighty god only created
documents fragment
caste
nam raja ram
monay la
y from a single pair of male and female
and have divided y into nations and tribes
so that you shall regna each other not that you shall
dispatch each other and the  Most superior in the sight of
Allah is the person Taqwa the
criteria for judgement is not caste it's
not colour it's not wealth it's not sex but it is
Taqwa it is good consciousness it is
righteousness it is piety Allah says in the
Quran in surah Isra chapter number 17 verse
number 70 Wa Kar Adama we have been nerds the
children of Adam whether you are born in Hindu
family and Christian from Muslim family if you are bani Adam if you are
human being you have been
nerd in Islam all human beings are
equal the only way you can be superior is by
Taqwa it's by good consciousness it's by
piety it's by righteousness so I degree with
this concept what I believe and there are many
schools from this has been incorporated so that the
higher class the Brahmans could rule what they came
in the philosophy you are a Shudra you are a
Shudra  Loka behave lak shudra if you serve me
better in the next life you will become a good
person but in this life you serve me so this I believe
is not the word of almighty god that is the reason
reform of Hindu they spoke against caste
system against brahmin kum song to me if you
allow this caste system i color and the
religious scripture should be done by anyone weather
rich and poor weather businessman weather warrior
weather king because this is a book of the
creator almighty god and everybody should know what our
creator wants us to do hope
im srinivas and im working in some
company on searching for in
my teenage
and
i some started searching now quran and
travelling through india it is at different place a different
time i used to come across people who were
travelling with me and i yet tell me something about
quran and all that and  Of
course I pray to God and finally only Saint
Jahangir Bhai and Kesar Didi gave me every
detail regarding the Quran
and I am very much convinced with the truth
the Quran speaks and I am happy to announce that I took
my Shaada this evening before this
session
takbeer in r action haal
and ma I just have few qur to post to
Mr Zakir Nayak till I don't
have Quran with me I just yar
people reading Quran and out ot just memra few
verses one from Quran 174 from that Allah
gave you sons and took daughters from the angels
truly yar aa meen you at all aar verses I do
understand this one thing the second thing is that it is
Harur Harur the vibrations of men in heaven and
some friends like spirit
forms r to every r sari r har comp ya in the
heavens ran r akr Badr most welcome  Come the
region of peace thank you my
request one of the viewers please get
the translation of the Quran of sahih international
please get it yes inshallah
and some the translation of the Quran
inshallah I give to you copy of the translation
so you can have a translation of the Quran with
inshallah regarding question the verse in the
Quran says that you give daughters to almighty God
and sons for yourselves this verse is rating as I told
you in my talk that Allah says in
Quran in sara ilas chapter 112 rs number the
l bagate not na button almighty God didn't have any
children so in argument to that they say that you give children to
God leave aside giving children you give daughters
to God and
sons for yourself it is a rhetoric
question first of all giving children to
God is right and leave therefore you gave daughters to God and
I gave  sat ban soti timet soti sun mo
super so r did and allan Quran in Maryam ch
8 alat awan ala i
most th ya se ith
man it
bist i b ma
asd falling and i de an ded b open i mounted
falling the mountain w spat asar the earth wd
st open so there four to say Allah
began a son is the biggest abus so these verses
Allah subhan taala he uses many
things as rhetoric Allah aso says tell to them if
Allah had the son I would be the first
person to bow down to him rhetoric a rhetoric
that means if Allah had a son I would be the
first person to bow down indicating
Allah does not have any son so similarly this
is another rhetoric use in the Quran that if you say that
Allah has got son you give daughters to
Allah and son to Russells so all the verses
are indicating the Almighty  God does not bother, it
begins and does not bother come to the second
question about the company the word that you
mention in sale places about Allah mentions
four times in the Quran in the Quran Chapter
number 52 in the shop Chapter number 44 Sir Rahman
Chapter 55 Wak Chapter 56 Four times the
word is mentioned in the Quran it is talking about
the company in the year after one you go to this
life the taste in the year after if you go to
Jannah your
company describing that they have big
beautiful and they will be the question put
in Jannah if you go to Jannah if the man will get
beautiful one what will the woman get men will get
beautiful women in Jannah
in paradise what will the woman get from this question one has to ask
Allah please so she said that they will get what
The heart has
desired what I have seen what I have heard me Even
the woman for the company in the janna Even they get something what
the hand has
desired what the eye has seen and were a nerd The
description of janna They are giving
you Highlights What can happen in janna There can be
rivers flowing of milk and honey If you are
rich person You can have rivers of milk
flowing between your feet But that milk is
different than the milk that we know The fruit Talk about
in the janna is different what you know The one who
talk about that is different than the girl that
you know It is nothing Companion to Miss World and Miss
Universe
[Appreciation]
So I would
request all the brothers and sisters who have questions
to please form so the women get a share of
unity to identify
this movement Peace to Humanity Really a
movement it needs  In our country but the core is
not based on the religion please understand
the division in this country is not based on the
religion it is not based on the God it is not
based on the Scripture it is based on
self interest politicians and certain
communities certain caste who feel that they are
the superior and they should control the country they
create in the name of region they are fighting in the
name of odd everyone no god same everyone no worship same god but their
credit is the superior please come what may it politically I did
mention the British had the
policy of divide and rule and
unfortunately most of the politicians have
inheritance and rule so there for the talk I have told that if all
the Indians the Hindus
and the Muslims if you go back to the
Scripture those people are all Satan Allah
says in the Quran  In Sir Bakra Chapter 168
I Am You Believe Do Not Follow The Devil The
Foot Of The Devil So We Get Impressed By
This Politician There Forer We Should Go Back
To The Scripture
And Follow Then Inshallah We Will Not Follow From
People And Come Back And Request You
Politician If You Try To Get The Vote Back
By Getting To Abe They Get Their Back Ispat Bakra I
Am Pawan Kumar Sharma
Mechanical Engineer From Haryana
Red Some Verses Of Quran In Another Action Hal Dos
Verses Of Messenger Of God Should To Common
People To Common Men So You Should Come
To Mercy Of Allah And Allah Will
Bring Joy And Make Your Life Prosperous
And If You Not Come To The Messiah Of Allah Your
Life Is Ful Of Saro I Want To Know What This Here Allah Means Whether It Is
Almighty God And The God Is
Followed By  Only the messenger and God is one than what ever the religion is followed by
tribal people
and Almighty God will bring
prosperity to those people also
good question I request the
brother who accepted Islam I would like to present to him a
copy of the glorious
Quran translation I request the brother to come
on top
[Praise]
question the Quran that if you come to the
mercy of the mighty God he will take you to the
right path go atre so is he talking about
Allah only of that messenger and the different
messengers different Allah brother as I told in I talk that
Almighty God is only one but there are seven
messengers but all the messengers
preach the same message in the Quran by name 25
messengers are mentioned Adam Moses Ibrahim Jesus
Muhammad Peace be upon them all all the
messengers they preach the same message that believe
in one  Same God There is no different God for
Hindu and different God for Christian and
different God for Muslim All the human
beings have the same
God What we say is Arabic Allah You can give any
name to Almighty God but it should be a
good name It should be a beautiful name It should not create a
mental picture So here it says that
you come to the mercy of God Means that if
you follow the guidance of Almighty God The
guidance is given in the last and final
revelation The Quran Then Inshallah you will be
successful as I mention this life is the
test for the here after So all the messengers whether it be
Adam or Noah or Ibrahim or Moses or Jesus or
Muhammad Peace be upon them all All the
messengers they spoke about the same
Almighty God and they call all the human
beings to the same God Not different God
What we believe  That the message is kept on getting
corrupted so the moment the message gets
corrupted almighty god send a different
messenger same age bhagavad
gita chapter 5 verse number 10 when ever there is unrighteousness i come but who comes almighty god send the messenger in every age so here we understand that all the messengers preach the same message but the previous messages have been corrupted this is uncorrupted god says in sara hijr chapter 15 verse
9 i revealed this quran and i will get from
corruption hope the answer question do we have a
non muslim sister
this question is not about a non muslim sister ok
sister salam awaikum brother a non muslim sister don wa to be
identified
good when what are similarities bwi worship islam
and him apple than they go for pig shud muslim
go for hay aumd them
worship sf  the shaving head is one
region muslims go to have
shaving head
iram fraternity wil bar
god and namo her frmar style der ya funny man
and one they go to her stall her sl de
so n wish we are shaitan our lineage is due to the
mighty god
only in him the similar cut of shaving head
it matching ding sakley
the region wil
kate people object ilam is ship then why do we ask
the kaaba why do we ask the kaaba do your
worship the kaaba and the hindu ask an deity the
difference between the hindu
circumambulation muslim circumambulation is a difference
of chalk and cheese we bow to the kaaba sala it is as a
sign of direction it qibla kaaba is
qibla if we offer sala we have to offer in the
same direction today if we offer sala some will sit north samal from
south samal from east  From
west so for unity the muslims face
towards the
kaaba so those living in the west they face towards the
east those living in the east face the
west those in the north face the south those in the south
face the north and if you analyze the kaaba the
world map the first person do the world
map was al idra in
1154 when the muslims did the world map
north pole was at the bottom and south pole was at the
top and kaaba was in the center later on the
western cartography
kaaba is in the center
[praise]
the region we sit round the kaaba is because
allah told us as prophet we do it my
logical reason i can think is because every
circle has one center one we sit and around the
kaaba we are testifying that there is only one
almighty god but if you sit round the kaaba and
believe many gods then doing
and regarding worship the statement of
hazrat umar b please see what is  Mention in Sahih
Bukhari volume number two in the book of Hajj he said that
I am kissing this black
stone this black stone can neither benefit
me nor harm me I am kissing it just because of
my prophet that this statement of Hazrat Umar is to
testify that no Muslim worships the Kaaba
and furthermore my argument is that since the time
of the Prophet Muhammad (peace be upon him) who studied the Kaaba
and gave birth to no ideal worship will ever be seen as the ideal worship so
this prophet Muslim do worship the
Kaaba it is said and regarding
other similarities there are other similarities there are various other forms
of worship in Hinduism one form of worship is known as
kaaba and ana
part of the
body one type of worship is in Hinduism
touching at part of the body the
best you can do is like a Muslim
touching our nose  our two hands two knees and
two feet tongue eight parts of the body for head
nose two hands two knees and two
feet and sujood is the best part of the salah it
is mention in the Quran and further
regarding Mecca the place of Mecca is in
the Hindu scripture the word mention
for Mecca in Hinduism is Ela pada ela as it is said is
God and it means place so Ela
pada is one of the place of Tirtha place of
Pilgrim which is mention in Rigveda book
number three hi number 29 verse number 5 Ela pada
in the sasak diri pada place of God house of
God it is the place of ta place of pilgrim same thing as in
Quran in ira Imran chapter 3
verse 96 the first place for worship wa baqa for
Mecca so Mecca is in mention in the Hindu
scripture and it says that this Ela pada will be
in the Nether Earth the center of the Earth as it is told
You Kaaba is in the center of earth and from
the few verses later Rigveda Book No.
11 Hi No. 29 Verse No. 11 says it talks about
Nara Prasana the Prophet who called the Praiseworthy
so because this Prophet also said it is very clear
cut that one of the
places the Hindus should go for pilgrimage is the
Mecca above the An Qayan
[Praise]